good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight the sad news and you
know this already is that more than 22
million people have filed for
unemployment benefits recently since our
government instituted mass quarantines
have began shutting down the economy in
state after state according to Pew as of
right now fully 43 percent of all
Americans have seen their hours cut
their pay cut or lost their jobs
entirely that means a huge chunk of the
country is now wondering how to pay the
bill some have run out of money entirely
and they're hungry lines at food banks
are the longest in nearly a hundred
years since the depression so whatever
you think of our uniquely generous
immigration policy maybe you support it
it's pretty clear that right now is
literally the last moment that
unemployed Americans should have to be
undercut by foreign nationals as they
look for desperately needed jobs it's
obvious and the president knows it well
last night without warning he tweeted
this quote in light of the attack from
the invisible enemy as well as the need
to protect the jobs of our great
American citizens I will be signing an
executive order to temporarily suspend
immigration into the United States end
quote
well that ricocheted around Twitter
immediately the announcement seemed to
come out of nowhere but in fact it
didn't Americans have been consistently
demanding this and it's measurable the
new Ipsos poll found that a remarkable
79 percent of all American adults
support a temporary suspension of all
immigration into the country for the
duration of this pandemic a Harvard
Harris poll found that 83 percent of
adults 83% won a moratorium on
immigration from Mexico and by the way
these are not new sentiments they've
been around a long time another Harvard
poll from two years ago found that
eighty-one percent of voters wanted a
legal immigration cut to below its
current level of about a million people
a year sixty-three percent wanted that
number cut by half at least in a country
as divided as ours is right now this is
as close to a consensus as you're ever
going to find about anything ever if our
democracy is real and we're hoping it is
our leaders cannot continue to ignore
what the public wants and in this case
there's no question the president has
the authority to do what he has done
current federal law explicitly
authorizes a president any press
to suspend the immigration into the
country whenever he deems it detrimental
to the interest of the United States the
people who wrote that law were very
clear about why they did it during
hearings at the time they explicitly
pointed to epidemics and mass employment
as the kind of crises that would justify
cutting off immigration sound familiar
of course it does to most people that
makes an utter sense why in the middle
of a disaster would you make things
worse why would you hurt your own people
when they're already hurting even in
Europe that's very obvious to leaders
many European countries have closed
their borders during this disaster and
now making do with their own indigenous
labor force and yet some people in this
country still oppose the idea who are
these people and why do they oppose it
well people who've been pampered and
enriched by waves of low wage
immigration they're against it
politicians whose hopes for power rest
on changing this country's population
oppose it too they'd rather see
Americans unemployed in fact anyone
whose livelihood depends upon selling
out the country is apt to be very
threatened by this former Secretary of
State Madeleine Albright is squarely in
that category Albright has spent the
last 20 years bowing before and then
profiting from the government of
Communist China
Albright was one of the shills who
lobbied for China's disastrous admission
into the World Trade Organization 20
years ago
she's now appalled by the notion of
cutting immigration during the worst
unemployment crisis of our lifetimes as
she just explained an MSNBC that's
immoral how do you feel about the
president's messaging on immigration
well I'm stunned and I really do think
that the Statue of Liberty is weeping
it is unamerican got that it's
unamerican to act in the economic
interests of Americans that's Madeleine
Albright's position but at least you'll
say this for us she seemed coherent as
she said it former presidential
candidate Robert bado O'Rourke who is
technically unemployed himself though
still very rich erupted in a primal
scream when he heard the news he tweeted
this quote who the F do you think is
working on the farms and feedlots and
the packing houses and processing plants
at a time when we are struggling to feed
ourselves who is in the kitchen who is
picking preparing serving the food we
eat
cleaning up afterwards well honestly
those are all very good questions if
you're an 18th century French Marquis as
the country falls apart around him but
toes first and main concern is
preserving America's sacred caste system
the native-born working on farms in
kitchens in factories sacre bleu scrapes
bateau it's unnatural unthinkable it is
wrong we must have a compliant
underclass we must who will iron the
sheets you can just imagine poor Bhutto
sitting alone in his study fretting
about the coming peasant rebellion but
it turns out he needn't have worried
just before air time the president
announced the substance of his executive
order and it's possible this will change
so we're just going on what we heard
from the podium but it's this the new
moratorium and immigration will last for
60 days at which point it could be
extended or it may not be extended the
ban will apply only to individuals
seeking permanent residency in this
country in other words people who like
the United States enough to stay
permanently and would like green cards
to be able to do it legally but the ban
will not apply to those entering the
United States on a temporary basis and
that means this will not affect guest
workers that's an awful lot of
exceptions every year our government
hands out 80,000 non-agricultural guest
worker visas as well as 85,000 h-1b
visas and hundreds of thousands of Ag
worker visas the purpose of this tidal
wave of immigration has nothing to do
with what advocates of immigration claim
immigration is for these visas do not
improve American society in any way we
have no moral obligation to give them
there is no mention of guest workers on
the Statue of Liberty there's only one
point in handing out hundreds of
thousands of these visas to foreign
nationals and is to placate big business
employers always in everywhere want to
hire workers for less in this case for
less than Americans make and these visas
let them do it and now they'll continue
to do it at a time when more than 22
million Americans have just filed for
unemployment you may have just lost your
job but you'll be happy to know that
Accenture can still import IT workers
from Asia who will work for
than you once made so if the point of
this executive order was to protect
American jobs maybe there was another
point but if it was to protect American
jobs it failed so how did this happen
exactly well we are not sure that we do
plan to find out for now we can make a
few educated guesses the first is this
the president is worried about
preserving American jobs he says that
frequently to people around him he
clearly means it he ran on that issue in
2016 and of course he won on it
unfortunately and this seems to be the
key some in his orbit are not as
concerned their main worry is making
donors happy and if there's one thing
that donors love always it's cheap
employees
yes our middle class is dying at a
faster clip than ever before no this
will not help them but that's not the
problem of these advisors they don't
know many of these people personally
anyway these people may be poor but
they're not the fashionably poor the
ones people in Los Angeles write songs
about her raise money for it mixers
they're just normal Americans whose
lives and futures and families have
taken a terrifying dive that they may
not recover from but whatever some of
the people with influence hanging around
the White House have more profound
things to worry about right now than the
fate of America is dying middle-class
they're worried about whether their
friends will approve of the president's
latest executive order that's their
attitude and it's that attitude that
brought us where we are right now who
are we talking about we're not naming
names side because we haven't confirmed
who they are more to come